[Music]
in full display news dp/dt PTP submitted
by knights hussein i nee 9i a
performance artist who exposed her
genitals and the louvre faces
prosecution for exhibitionism exactly so
she was just like the skirt I did too
but this girl Bonjour she Christ I don't
want those golden chairs why was that
the loo right
Duluth yeah the the glass triangle
Museum yeah the Louvre in Paris yeah
they have golden chairs which one yeah
they have those rooms with all these
golden everything oh it was like the
kings area I know are you are you in
about the zoom in the Queen's palace of
versaille oh you did it yeah oh wait
they do have rooms that are like Palace
design decorated there's some fancy [ __ ]
bishop i sat on their dirty ass you know
that's been a museum for a very long
time
what hy dilute for a very very long time
what's very very long time I don't even
know I just know it's old oh but before
that it was a castle yeah because if you
go down on the way out
you know how there's all those big brick
things oh yeah yeah and then they say
before this was a castle and then on top
of the cache so they built that Elysium
there was a Chinese tour right oh yeah a
Chinese circuit and I was just saying
that if there was a Chinese tour guide
explaining to his uh no this woman her
name is Deborah she she doesn't sound
very French oh you know Chinese tourists
almost stampeded over Jess when we were
at the loo
yeah what because she got caught like in
the this balcony area taking pictures
yeah and then I looked over and then
there was like a sea of Chinese tourists
coming toward us with freaking cameras
no sign I'm trying to get this picture
and I'm like [ __ ] they all just
surrounded her and started trying to
take pictures of her and she was like
holy [ __ ] I can't get out and I'm all
like oh you pushed her us to get out
back to Deborah so she has dual
nationalities or French and American
don't see American she's from Luxembourg
Luxembourg Ian or how would you say a
person that's from their looks and
burgers some bergens you know Luxembourg
is its own country right so when you
went to the Luxembourg garden is that
the same thing or is it just the name of
it it's just a name I know we're still
in Paris okay I let some Brits outside
of France oh yeah yeah we're still in
Paris I don't know [ __ ] about European
geography about [ __ ] she is an artist
and she was saying that so I'm gonna
show you what she did show me her lips
this is what she did
oh look wait how did she get so close to
the [ __ ] phone with you like how does
she cross that freaking thingy maybe she
wants cowboy and black gosh sure she's
sitting on the floor can't tell if you
know so
so she's seen [ __ ] front of people
why are you I wear a top at that it's
art yeah this isn't they're trying to
take her up it looks nice ladies like
what the [ __ ] she looks like I thought I
had a different photo but you could see
like where you know where you lean up
against the rail and then there's like
that the glass casing and then right
there there's like a long wooden table
that's what she's sitting on but it
looks short in this boat
me and Christina got to go there in
front of everyone cuz you're a pregnant
cuz she was pregnant and I had her on a
wheelchair I was pushing around the
Louvre if she had to walk that whole
thing she would have not lasted
I barely lasted I'm not even pregnant up
is huge I know I kept trying to just
where's the Mona Lisa let's just go see
it because we have some other [ __ ] to do
later and it took us forever to get
there dude the the it felt like it was a
Justin Bieber concert like the crowded
yeah the way people thirst for Mona Lisa
wait were you with I mean yeah yeah do
you remember how [ __ ] sweaty people
were like oh like they're just taking
pictures and I'm all I do like you can't
appreciate the [ __ ] painting if
you're like you know how small it is
right yeah and so they're like halfway
in the room and they're just like trying
to take a [ __ ] picture like pushing
forward what the [ __ ] dude it's I mean
it's a painting but you got to see what
your own eyes man like and everyone's
trying to take pictures I was one of
those people in there and I was right in
the front I was and then I was done
taking my photos that Isaac Casey I read
from selfies everything I was just like
soak it in like I was just trying to
appreciate it you know I thought the
Mona Lisa was a lot bigger
yeah me too everyone thinks that like
this [ __ ] bleeding [ __ ] huge it's
the whole wall and then up the Eiffel
Tower is one that [ __ ] me up because I
thought it was gonna be smaller than
what it really is
no Vegas right and then I went there and
I'm like oh I had the same reaction too
oh my goodness [ __ ] keep yeah just
the base of one of like one of the for
like legs I'm like oh my [ __ ] god I
think that was me like all over France
like watching documentaries and seeing
the buildings they're a lot smaller but
I just think that they're like
present-day construction and when you
get there it was like what the [ __ ] this
is like a wonder of the world like this
yeah this is huge like damn dude someone
had a theme park for a home like what
the [ __ ] is this crazy ass of Deborah
here she did that and she did that she's
saying that she did it because she was
she's warning huh horny she's trying to
copy a photograph by another performance
artist David an Austrian performance art
artist named valley export and so this
artist was famous for doing a similar
stunt back in the 70s so she's that even
original artist she's just a [ __ ]
parody person there's no copycat yeah
she sucks
she's just jacking ideas she's wack I
hate when people try to use like these
stupid opportunities as an excuse to say
like oh this is my art and all that is
like you're not doing anything but
bothering people
like what what are you really doing like
people she says is her message so she
says my message is to question the place
of women artists in the history of art
that's why it's necessary to do my
performances and museums there's people
that are killing it though actual women
killing it in museums now she's a
disgrace to to nation' Atalissa
I mean you can't you really can't argue
with artists because art is supposed to
induce some sort of like feeling right
so the fact that we're talking about
we're like what the [ __ ] she's waste
it's like where she it it worked
but she's copying someone else too
though yeah so her her art is annoyance
so that means most trolls are artists
cuz I think she just told everybody if I
spit
all this [ __ ] money to go to the
Louvre to take you know pictures of Mona
Lisa and sweat my greasy ass off next to
a bunch of tourists I want to do that I
don't want to see some [ __ ] hairy ass
[ __ ] blocking the way like dude you're
[ __ ] up my picture I would have
grabbed her arm swiped her and been like
no I came to see her and I you you know
if you saw that know there's been your
highlight of the trip it would have been
hilarious
so maybe it would have been cool but at
the same time I would I'm just thinking
about the people that saved up all this
money that got in and then it's all so
crowded they waited a long time hear it
but she just
yeah she's [ __ ] up the experience
yeah if she wanted to do that why don't
she just perform like somewhere else
I booked a venue yeah gaffur a [ __ ]
like show yeah wasn't the first time
just done this she's been arrested for
indecent exposure before we're at the
Orsay Museum oh another French Museum so
what is her state like is she trying to
show like like erotic art or just what
is it like if it's women in the art
place I feel like there's plenty of
women artists out there that that are
skill based not just shock value like
this I think what goes against her is
the fact that it's not original yeah
just claiming to be an artist but she's
copying someone else and it's not skill
based there's a lot of female painters
like that spent years and years learning
a craft and it's skill based versus like
anybody that's kind of crazy can go out
there and be naked and like look I'm
[ __ ] causing a disruption I could go
up there start jacking off in front of
everybody and being like this is my
performance
maybe she spent hours trimming her pubes
in that blurry [ __ ] did not look like a
shape other than you would never know we
can't see you
I could tell when's her next concert
we're people that are interested well
she's not facing trial on charges of
sexual exhibitionism and her next show
that the call assault because she yea
the courthouse assault because she bit
the jacket or unsecured crazy
that was her performance right but yeah
so they've heard easy
her lawyer here saying that it's not
exhibitionism if there is no wish to
assault someone sexually which is
completely contrary to the work of this
performance artist hmm it's not work
it's just [ __ ] annoyance man I don't
know I don't like people hiding behind
the veil of art it's like this you
really spent years and years like doing
practicing this and developing a skill
set and like I don't know I mean that's
how I feel about abstract art especially
the ones I've just paint paint splatters
on a canvas cuz I'm just like anyone can
kind of do that yeah I could get some
[ __ ] painting oh yeah million dollars
see I don't know abstract art is not my
thing though because I just frustrates
me but then I also feel like that's the
point of abstract artist because just
like how Jia was saying earlier is
supposed to like bring out a feeling or
like even just start a conversation and
for me it's like it just makes no sense
because there's really no skill in it
you just splat paint on it so that's the
thing though exactly but that's the goal
of abstract or is to make you hate it
yeah and to have you bond with other
people and talk [ __ ] about how my
[ __ ] kindergarten nephew can do a
better job of this [ __ ] if you guys
are shocked art look I'm sorry but I'm
more of a technic I'm not sorry don't be
sorry girl don't that's my art it's
[ __ ] garbage hey guys I hope you
enjoyed that episode of just kidding
News and if you did really enjoy it or
if you have thoughts about what you just
watched
leave a comment down below and let us
know and for the next video click right
up here
[Music]